[Music]
[Music]
far too often animated movies are
written off as overly kid-friendly
unsophisticated fluff when the truth is
the medium is capable of telling stories
as mature as the most prestigious
live-action dramas sometimes however an
animated movie ostensibly made for
children can also be spooky enough to
terrify the most hardened youngsters and
even a few adults like me
don't look back
i look bad
so whether they were intentionally
spooky or simply featured a couple of
freaky moments that made every kid hit
fast forward we put together a list of
the scariest animated movies that
terrified the young audiences they were
meant to entertain
[Music]
number 10 monster house
monster house is ultimately charming and
fun for most but this is after all the
only proper horror film on this list and
while it's largely kid-friendly it's
also suitably frightening in spots as
any haunted house movie should be the
film follows three kids who decide to
explore the creepy old house in their
neighborhood with a terrifying
reputation it feels like a 1980s amblin
movie full of adventure and comedy and
more than a little danger thanks to a
few intense scenes courtesy of the
imaginatively rendered house as la
weekly scott founders said of the film
monster house becomes one of those
wonderfully weird adventure stories
beloved of children who don't mind
getting a good old-fashioned case of the
heebie-jeebies it's kind of a blast for
adults too critics say monster house
welcomes kids and adults alike into a
household full of smart monstrous fun
but if i let her go
i'll have no one
that's not true
oh
the house
what are you doing trying to fill the
house down
ah
[Music]
[Music]
good
[Music]
number nine the last unicorn
horror and fantasy are two genres that
don't cross nearly enough but when they
do they offer unique experiences the
last unicorn skews more towards fantasy
but it still packs enough spooky
elements to make it a scary film for
kids rank and bass may be better known
for their holiday classics like the stop
motion animated rudolph the red-nosed
reindeer but this fantasy epic about a
unicorn who discovers she is the last of
her kind and embarks on a quest to
discover what has happened to her kin is
full of horrific dangers without a doubt
the most frightening for kids was the
fiery red bull evil incarnate with its
deep blood red color and almost hollow
eyes that no doubt inspired countless
nightmares writing about the film for
time out jeff andrew explained that the
last unicorn has some horrific moments
the mark of the best fairy tales and
some sublimely witty lines critics say
the last unicorn lacks the fluid
animation to truly sparkle as an
animated epic but offbeat characters and
an affecting story make it one of a kind
for the true believers
[Music]
do as you will magic do as you will
[Music]
have you done
[Music]
what have you done
what have you done
number eight the great mouse detective
a noir mystery starring mice may not
necessarily seem like a film that would
give you nightmares for days on end but
you would be wrong based on the
children's novel basil baker street
which itself was inspired by the tales
of sherlock holmes the great mouse
detective starts with a little mouse
girl named olivia celebrating her
birthday with her father at home when
suddenly a one-legged bat breaks into
the house and kidnaps the father the
film's eerie atmosphere persists
throughout its run time and even when
there are moments of levity or sweetness
they're usually followed by moments of
utter terror for many children the bat
represents their first experiences with
jump scares as he is responsible for the
two most frightening ones in the film
first when he bursts into olivia's home
at the beginning of the movie and later
when he leaps out of a baby carriage to
abduct her small children may be afraid
of some of the bad characters the disney
studios gift for creating really nasty
bad guys means that they are scary but
they will love the cute brave mice and
cheer their triumphs adults will enjoy
the whit and style critics say the great
mouse detective may not rank with
disney's classics but it's an amiable
entertaining picture with some stylishly
dark visuals
[Applause]
oh
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
i can't
[Music]
number seven watership down
it doesn't take long for watership down
to shed its cute bunny film facade and
reveal a deeper allegory that flows red
with blood this adaptation of richard
adams's novel follows a group of rabbits
on a perilous journey to find refuge
after one of them has an apocalyptic
vision about their home for generations
watership down has traumatized children
with hunting imagery of red-eyed rabbits
ripping each other's throats out or
suffocating as they're buried alive and
peril lies around every turn in the
story walter cha of film freak central
summed it up succinctly unsentimental
and terrifying critics say aimed at
adults perhaps more than children this
is a respectful beautifully animated
adaptation of richard adams beloved book
[Music]
i told you once i was trying to impress
you
i hope i have
and i told you that i would kill you
myself
there's no white bird here big week
[Music]
why throw your life away
cracker
sir
come out
my chiefs told me to defend this run
number six scooby-doo on zombie island
for decades scooby-doo and the mystery
incorporated gang have served as an
introduction to horror for kids offering
mildly creepy stories that always ended
with an ah shucks and a smile well not
scooby-doo on zombie island which marked
the first time the gang faced a real
supernatural threat as they set out to
find ghosts and monsters in louisiana
what starts as another typical
scooby-doo adventure quickly devolves
into a tale of voodoo ghost pirates
vengeful cat demons and of course
zombies all tied together by a tragic
backstory much darker than fans of the
show would have been accustomed to there
aren't any greedy tycoons and rubber
suits here and actual death of werecats
and humans alike is a major element of
the plot there really isn't anything
else quite like this in the scooby-doo
canon and any kid going into it
expecting the usual antics was in for a
shock trace thurman from horror queers
podcast says this film retains the
scooby-doo ip's goofy charms while
simultaneously working as a surprisingly
dark form of gateway horror for children
also it's perfect
on your mark get set ignition
hey no fair
what's the matter chicken
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
uh
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
marks
[Music]
like i think we ditched him buddy
number five coraline
on the surface this stop-motion
adaptation of neil gaiman's novel is a
silly story of a spunky bored little
girl who finds a hidden door to a secret
world where everything is perfect yet
slightly off but just like its hidden
parallel dimension coraline is freaky
and frequently plain horrifying as soon
as coraline finds a secret door the
story begins to unfold like a horror
film ramping up its creepy atmosphere
and frightening creatures but the real
terror comes from the moment coraline is
given her own set of button eyes to be
sewn on by her creepy other mother
before she transforms into a giant
spider and all hell breaks loose moira
mcdonald summarized it for the seattle
times by saying quote children who like
being scared will get a kick out of this
wildly creative movie adults needn't
have a child in tow to enjoy it too
critics say with its vivid stop-motion
animation combined with neil gaiman's
imaginative story coraline is a film
that's both visually stunning and
wondrously entertaining after all
you still need to find your old parents
don't you
too bad you won't have
this
be clever miss even if you win she'll
never let you go
[Music]
i already know where you've hidden them
well
produce them
they're behind that door
oh they are
are they
[Music]
mom
dad
go on
open it
they'll be there all right
you're wrong
coraline
they aren't there
now
you're going to stay here
forever
no
i'm
not
number four the secret of nim if you
thought animated movies featuring
talking animals were all sunshine and
rainbows think again this film based on
the children's novel mrs frisby and the
rats of nim follows a field mouse as she
tries to save her ill son both from his
pneumonia and from the farmer whose land
they live on before he plows through it
dawn bluth's adaptation is full of truly
terrifying moments involving the
survivors of scientific experiments
including a rat-eating cat named dragon
but the scene that really traumatized
kids was the visit to the great owl
whose introduction includes a layer
littered with bones of his devoured prey
a gruesome encounter with an ill-fated
spider and a pair of creepy glowing eyes
that stared into your very soul bluth's
films also skewed a little darker than
typical disney fair and this was a prime
example of his aesthetic as critic
christopher noll wrote for film critic
dot com never mind the g rating this is
scary stuff which sent my little one
fleeing to another room inside of 10
minutes critics say the secret of nim is
a dark well-told tale that respects its
young audience enough to not tone down
its subject matter
[Music]
[Music]
oh
[Music]
why have you come
[Music]
please
forgive me for disturbing you but
my son's life is in great danger
[Music]
the plow has come early this year
move your family
[Music]
yes
i wouldn't move
but timothy has pneumonia
he can't even get out of bed
you must move to a place
[Music]
number three the nightmare before
christmas
ask any horror fan and they'll tell you
that christmas and horror make for a
fantastic combination but this is one of
the rare times that the two cross over
in animated form and it's mostly a
delightful treat from the mind of tim
burton and henry selick comes the story
of the pumpkin king of halloweentown
jack skellington who gets tired of the
same annual festivities and decides to
kidnap santi claus and take over
christmas as sweet and funny as it is
terrifyingly gruesome the nightmare
before christmas is a visual treat even
if those visuals are frequently bizarre
off-kilter and a little macabre for the
toddler set the best example is the
burlap sack villain oogie boogie who
literally refers to himself as the
boogeyman and who meets his demise when
he comes apart at the seams and reveals
he's full of creepy crawlies as alan
jones wrote for the radio times only the
deliciously demented imagination of
edward scissorhands director tim burton
could have come up with such a dark
vision of the holiday season critics say
the nightmare before christmas is a
stunningly original and visually
delightful work of stop-motion animation
sandy claws
[Music]
you wait till jack hears about this by
the time he's through with you you'll be
lucky the king of halloween has been
blown to smithereens
skeleton jack is now a pile of dust
come on zero
christmas isn't over yet
[Music]
what's that you were saying about luck
ragdoll
[Music]
[Music]
ashes to ashes and dust to dust
oh
i'm feeling weak
with hunger
one more roll of the dice oughta do it
[Music]
[Applause]
and sandman
[Music]
number two who framed roger rabbit
wait a second who framed roger rabbit is
a live action movie you might say and
you'd be mostly correct but robert
zemeckis's loony live action animated
hybrid deserves a spot on this list
because it features one of disney's
scariest villains christopher lloyd's
judge doom who spoiler alert is actually
a cartoon himself when we first meet
doom he mercilessly murders an innocent
tune without flinching dumping into a
vat of corrosive dip then comes the
pivotal moment when we discover doom's
true identity as played by lloyd he
already resembled a half-desiccated
corpse a cross between the evil preacher
from the poltergeist movies and the
gestapo officer from raiders of the lost
ark who gets his face melted off but
once he's run over by the steamroller
and pops back up doom is another beast
altogether and the stuff of childhood
nightmares critics say who framed roger
rabbit is an innovative and entertaining
film that features a groundbreaking mix
of live action and animation with a
touching and original story to boot
[Music]
i wasn't worried for you
[Applause]
[Music]
hey
[Music]
holy smoke he's a tomb
surprise not really
that lame brave freeway idea could only
be cooked up by a tune
not just
[Music]
[Music]
and finally number one spirited away
japanese animation maestro haiyo
miyazaki's films have been described as
beautifully made artistic wonders and
visual masterpieces but frightening
isn't a sensation you normally associate
with his work that being said spirited
away is his most haunting film and it is
more than its fair share of creepy
moments that sneak up on you and make a
lasting impression the story of a girl
lost in a world ruled by spirits is as
whimsical as a disney film but it
doesn't shy away from disturbing imagery
like when young protagonist chihiro sees
her parents transformed into monstrous
and endlessly hungry pigs or when the
spirit no face begins to devour all the
employees of the bathhouse in a wild
frenzy children who toughed it out
through the more frightening moments
were rewarded with an enchanting magical
experience but for some kids that would
have been a tall order critics say
spirited away is a dazzling enchanting
and gorgeously drawn fairy tale that
will leave viewers a little more curious
and fascinated by the world around them
try this it's delicious
want some gold i'm not giving it to
anybody else
[Music]
come closer sin what would you like
just name it
i would like to leave sir i have some
place i need to go to right away please
you should go back to where you came
from you baba doesn't want you in the
bath house any longer
where is your home don't you have any
friends or family
no
no
i'm lonely
i'm lonely
what is it that you want i want sin i
want sin
take the gold take it are you going to
eat me take it
huh
if you want to eat meat eat this first
i was saving this for my parents but i
think you'd better have it
[Applause]
well friends that about does it for us
be sure to stay tuned to the rotten
tomatoes channel for more of the
entertainment content you love and for
even more news scores and
recommendations on the latest tv shows
and movies head on over to
rottentomatoes.com until next time i'm
your host naz perez and we'll see you
back here for more top 10s on the rotten
tomatoes countdown
[Music]
you